uh impede on facebook asks if
super-powered beings existed would you
be for registering them and their powers
oh that is a good one that's interesting
cuz that's a yes yeah you gotta track it
okay cuz cuz suppose one of them turns
bad you want to be able to and they have
such fun it's like it's like these hands
are registered weapon you know like when
you you know should we register just
north and there's the first one um no my
favorite Chuck Norris wanted it's Chuck
Norris can kill two stones with one bird
good my favorite one
on a sidenote sorry no Chuck Norris
we'll get back to the question there's a
Chuck Norris restaurant in Iceland what
is that name Reykjavik it's like a truck
Norris themed bar below restaurant was
just there a couple years ago fission
knew no it'd been there for a while how
come nobody told me I was there what
does it need for a restaurant to be
Chuck Norris theme there's just a lot of
trick you just punch you in the face
with it it's just I think it's their
idea of what like American culture well
Chuck Norris a lot of barbeque okay all
right I'm 321 right but anyway okay so
so you're you think there should be a
registry I think if you have powers
beyond everyone that could save as well
as hard mmm we I want to know that
you're there in it and so I can invoke
the absence of non registration in the
Constitution in this and say they should
all be registered and you can't invoke
the Second Amendment to not okay so I
would agree with that angle it if the
one of them went rogue oh my god yeah
they would cause a whole court awful
alright um but I think you are correct
that with their powers there are some
that could be dangerous or your hands
could be an actual weapon so like a gun
you register it right what is that the
Second Amendment person yeah you know
register of a basement full of mutant
yeah I mean also it depends what's the
percentage of the population so say 50
percent of the population are you really
going to register half the population
like we're talking abut if you have to
publish your superheroes that's a
different world yeah
the door no no thank you
what's a percent at which you would be
like if it's 1% or less we should
register at 10% or more like it yeah to
much yeah yeah that's why i q4 how do
you enforce this how do we know that
these are mutants are enhanced people
unless they control doing things like
like in in the movie unbreakable mmm-hmm
all right the main character starts
doing things that people notice yeah and
then all of a sudden shows up in the
papers and that's true for Batman and
you know thought Batman right so so you
I think it's hard to hide these talents
if you were otherwise gonna call you a
superhero it's because you're
manifesting talents that's all
well you could also have powers that you
don't use if you never use them it's a
moot point well you could use them
secretly isn't as harshly and she's like
like meeting lots of you could easily
have powers that you either secretly use
or illicitly use that's why you wanna I
can really use them its of no
consequence to anyone because it's a
secret that's my only point but what if
I could control people's minds
yeah or steal their hearts by turning my
hand invisible and phasing through and
to you and then yeah basically removing
their argument romantically I literally
feel people are from inside their body
like Indiana Jones to style right yeah
yeah typical doom stuff yeah yeah yeah
but more like like a like a really mean
kitty pryde have dead people with no
heart with dead people playing and you
know somebody was up to something that
is not doing it in secret that's my
point that's our point good show so he
agrees with a heart healer a heart
stealer so it's mine two for two now so
you don't think they should get
registered I don't know it's I think
it's a it's very complicated I remember
after the avenger after the lousy
hundreds came out there was an article
that was like you should absolutely
register people like like a nephron
Records totally wrong and it was like oh
that that makes sense so yeah I don't
know I think it depends on the scaler or
you'd have to figure it out more like
hunting down you well here's a point you
can register the Hulk and when he
becomes the Hulk there's nothing you can
do about it but yeah if he's registered
and you get a sense
where he is you can protect things from
him right you have some kind of just
peace of mind peace of Marco relating
for in fact like it's yeah but then it's
like a slippery slope so you have a
little girl that can turn invisible so
what do you end of thing where you know
you can look up if you do an x-men stuff
now right kind of thing yeah I don't
know yes you can depends what you can do
and what you gonna do you're gonna hunt
them all down I don't know that yeah
would it change our opinion on them
where it's like you could see all my
neighbors a registered mutant I want to
live here anymore
I can see value this house now cuz I
don't what they could just explode they
turn the problem would use is the
property value value I'm just trying to
think ahead for real estate exactly
really at marking in the real estate in
the Marvel Universe you are here very
inexpensive you haven't read that comic
Marvel real estate calm yeah
[Music]